this week in
feminism so yeah know I was just walking
to class oh my God penis I'm with a
[Music]
penis remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub for $89
annually join the fight at lwith
credit.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today got
[Music]
all right mug club and everybody else
thank you for joining us today we're got
a great show for you it's ladder with
crowded with Gerald they have a sign up
for me over here spared no expense you
can't you can't let people know you're
here before I let
people you're still talking it's still
happening all right thanks for joining
us look uh Stephen is very very ill
today he was doing uh legal things
yesterday I think you all know what that
means right now um and dealing with that
is no fun he was already sick prior to
that so we uh encouraged him to stay
home trust me he wanted to come in and
be a part of the show he misses you guys
and we'll be back tomorrow sitting in
the chair please don't take it out on me
just stay here don't don't click
anywhere else don't I get your finger
off the mouse stop do people still use
their desktop computers to watch this
don't push any buttons somewhere on the
telephones the things the brick whatever
we've got a good show for you I promise
it'll be a lot of fun I'm going to give
you a quick rundown of the stories we
had some hostages released well that
that's look that's fantastic I'm never
going to say no to hostages being
released but couldn't help but notice
you took them hostage in the first place
so I don't know if you necessarily get a
gold star uh Biden wants another $105
billion do they announced that they were
going to push for that last week we'll
dive into that uh we've got terrorist
coming across the southern border it's
kind of a problem we might want to look
into that and also do you remember art
Bri
the former head coach of Baylor who's
been making the news a little bit lately
yeah that was all Bs he's been cleared
and we're going to dive a little deeper
into that and maybe do a little bit of a
deep dive in revisiting me too and all
the Carnage and wreckage that that has
wrough on people's lives I understand
rape bad 100% sexual assault bad 100% we
want to bury those guys under the
courthouse but ruining people's lives uh
and not having any evidence and just
doing it for PR is a really really bad
thing now my question of the day before
I introduce the guests here is you guys
miss like the relative Global
Tranquility that we experienced under
Donald Trump comment below if you would
prefer to have that instead of as a lot
of people are saying right now
sleepwalking our way into World War III
all right for all of you we have a new
camera over here the fishey lens has
officially been retired and so I will
look better if that is possible yeah
when I'm sitting over there but right
now making that seat look very very nice
the brain Ginger Snap how are you sir
I'm hanging in there I'm chilling I'm
good learning where the microphone is
it's hard sometimes you got to get a
little closer right I'm just a naturally
a move around but that's not going to
work here in the microphone you're
sounding good man I mean if you want
people to hear you that is a very bad
thing to do but being closer to the
microphone is great just don't hide
behind also quick note on desktop
desktop computers I really like to watch
mine on those see-through Macs you know
from the 1990s that's fantastic listen I
understand I'm an old man and look when
you hear this song you know Mr Brian
kin's in the house how are you sir I'm
just a man sorry to ruin the surprise
everybody I don't think that you're just
a man well come on I'm although I don't
have the Auburn Hue to my hair that lane
does he's so fall looking I will take
Auburn and confirmed you do have a soul
correct um allegedly it's there
somewhere inaccessible at a lot of
points it lives under his tongue it
definitely does and Brian you'll be
using that tongue to make people laugh
that's what they say buddy in Chicago
that could have derailed very quickly in
Chicago October 27th and 28th well look
at that that's this Friday Friday
Saturday shamber he's not really in
Chicago it's actually shamberg 40
minutes outside of Chicago that's still
Chicago I mean I think you can say that
chag Chicago minus the gang seriously
minus the the
violence that was Siri listening to us
you don't want to hear what we're about
to say Siri really don't I love your new
uh your new po do we have the the new
kind of show show the the the thing for
his new show off limits it's on Mondays
on mug club boom look at that wow thank
you thank you to all the mug Club
listeners for your comments especially
the critical ones which I actually agree
with and I'm going to start reading off
the good ones that I like but they're
they're smart listeners they are very
smart listeners and I've realized that
you know I've always talk about one of
the things is you talk about being the
middle or talk about being reasonable
I'm not going to talk about that anymore
there's right and there's wrong yep how
about that hey how about that there we
go don't ask me if I'm in the middle or
the left or the right there's right or
there's wrong Brian's getting pissed
you're answering your own question
there's right and there's wrong ah yes I
see what you're doing there yeah the
left is typically wrong and look by the
way some of the stuff that we say here
is not necessarily fit for you know the
uh communist hell hole that is YouTube
and I don't really know why you're still
there do me a favor and go over to
rumble right now get off of YouTube but
look if at any point we start diving
into a subject that maybe could be uh I
don't know a foul of their stupid
guidelines that they leave open to
interpretation you're going to see
[Music]
this just make sure you head on over to
rumble uh during that time because we're
we're not trying to get banned all the
time I mean sometimes we try to get
banned and it's a lot of fun especially
when we do it on Tik Tok but um what we
have next for you is a uh it is Tik Tok
Tik Tok is is uh Satan I think it's a
clear way of saying that it's a really
bad place nothing good happens on Tik
Tok that I know of uh and we have our US
military right now with all of the
issues in the world and they're focused
on doing
this he's the one I'm leaving
[Music]
you no somebody wants to get taken
hostage why the beard line though why
the
[Music]
spoiler alert sorry bro that was wrong
that was wrong with me that was wrong
that is a guy let's clear you'd think
the drill sergeant would go through the
bag and find a makeup brush and kick the
crap out of him well yes unless yeah
unless it's today's military with of the
uh you know issues that we have facing
Us in the world and we're more concerned
with protecting people's ability look if
you want to dress up in Drag and do bad
makeup and like put a fake makeup beard
line in that makes you look like some
weird freaking futuristic character in a
show fine just don't do it on our dime
and certainly I 100 listen everybody has
a right to
serve I think they should see action if
action is had because that is what they
signed up for yes right just just a wall
I'm of I just don't just yeah I just I
don't feel safe with that person on my
wall that's my real question no but that
person is the wall how do we know that
that's a real military when we see these
how do we know these are real because
where are we seeing these Tik Tok right
interesting I've never really thought
about that before but how do we know
that these are really US military M I
think it's a a mpec makeup
brush I'm not like so it sucks we say
Tik Tok is one
giant it might be a giant that's that's
fair I do think our military is better
than that and I'm never I'm never by the
way messing with the entire military
it's just like when we talk about the
FBI or the CIA or you know Washington or
you know a lot of these other giant
agencies that are out there I I think
there's a lot of great soldiers I just
think the leadership is promoting some
really bad stuff and this is a symptom
of that not necessarily what leadership
is promoting they're probably not
handing out makeup brushes and saying go
and make yourself into a clown today and
uh see if you can pass yeah I don't know
that surpris well based on some of the
policies based on some of the things
that we've heard them say in their focus
look I think your focus should be on
fighting and winning wars period that's
it if let's just for and I'll get off
this but if you have two seconds to
consider if this is a scop it would make
sense because what you need to do is
degrade public trust in the institution
of the military and it is it is it is
lowest since 1997 since we're in the
middle of the Balkan Wars I believe
maybe even right after that but as soon
as you degrade public confidence then no
one wants to support the military then
you don't actually have confidence on
what they're doing and it's kind of this
Vicious Circle where you can't succeed
and no one wants to join it that's fair
why would the largest operator of
anti-American propaganda the CCP not
want to take advantage of their platform
that is our largest social media Network
for young people I don't
know it's Val it's interesting L 8D
chess or is it N I don't have any
substantiating evidence this just seems
like a good the I like that although if
you were in the if you were in the field
for a long long time and that was your
partner well you wouldn't be in the
field for what what I say golly I'm just
saying sometimes a man gets lonely in
the field and reel it in bro you can't
just tend to your sheep Brian what
happened I just I want you to look at me
at me sorry sorry it's just those lips
that the makeup even if yeah you're the
dominant one it's still gay okay so even
if I'm frowning the whole time and
singing the National Anthem come on man
still gay it's just
maintenance sorry still gay God damn it
if you want more of that or let's say
you don't let's say that you want more
of this show let's say you want more of
Alex Jones make sure you join mug Club
it is $89 annually it is the only way
that we keep the lights on and continue
to bring you great content but look
we've got a lot of great shows on here
we've got a lot of great contributors a
lot of talent we've also got some fun
stuff in the background that you don't
really see on a day-to-day basis but
you've started to see some of those
stories come through some of the
undercover stuff we've done some of the
stuff that laye you were able to go down
and do and get some footage uh you're
going to see more of that more of the
undercover work more of actually having
an impact in specific situations uh so
and that is only funded by m that the
only way that we can do that is with you
guys supporting us and look we don't
have tip jars all over the place we
don't have patreons we don't have super
chats we don't have a lot of this stuff
and that that's fine for other people to
have it that's just not how we do our
thing right we don't do a ton of
sponsorships because we want to make
sure that we bring you great content and
don't accidentally kind of slip into a
bowl and Branch ad right in the middle
of a a story right but we want to make
sure that we can bring you great great
content and also have an impact in the
communities on the topics that we talk
about all the time because we do have a
passion for it it's not just here to
talk about it we want to make an impact
and they're doing a great job with that
so they know who I'm talking about I
can't reveal it because you know the
whole undercover thing anyway so let's
get to the Israel story right now U one
of the biggest things in the news is
that Hamas apparently has released a
couple of hostages and that's I want
more than two yeah you give me 222 or
however many that there are right now I
think it's somewhere close to that
number but two elderly women were
actually taken hostage by Hamas and they
were released last night out of
captivity tonight 85-year-old Yos
livshits 79y old nor Cooper their
husbands are still thought to be in the
hands of
Hamas so w you saw the name 79-year-old
85-year-old were released to Egyptian
authorities and it says that their
husbands are remaining uh in captivity
and uh basically I think we were going
to trade Ilan Omar Rashida T and AOC but
Hamas took that as an act of aggression
and so um they decided to release these
two prisoners to us because they were
tired of changing their depends look
these are old people these are very very
old people that should never have been
taken hostage in the first place I'm
willing to bet their husbands are old
people as well I don't think they
married 25-year-old men that maybe it
would make sense in a conflict to try
and take off the battlefield I don't
think that's what happened and I don't
think he get a gold star for going and
releasing people that you took hostage
in the first place especially in a lot
of cases where you killed their children
in front of them or you killed other
family members in front of them or
killed their neighbors right before
taking them hostage you're a bad person
you are bad people you deserve whatever
the hell Israel wants to throw at you
now that doesn't mean I'm for War I am
just for getting these people out and
for Israel having the right to defend
themselves and if they got to go in and
break stuff and shoot people in the head
to get these people out then so be it
all right to be fair that the woman they
released was a peace activist and her
husband speaks Arabic and was very
active for years in helping Palestinians
in Gaza spend time in Gaza and knew
people in Gaza do you think that's why
they released them they probably
kidnapped them on accident my favorite
is apparently they were treated well as
in we kept you in a spiderweb of tunnels
but we did give you a mattress and some
Peta it's Blood Stained mattress because
you know those are in short supply but
we had to kill half your kots oh my God
and then we took you I know I mean unev
can you think like of any other
situation where it's like yeah we took
him hey we we released them we're good
guys now you're not good guys you still
hold 200 Israelis hostage from that
October 7th attack they said they
released them for humanitarian reasons
yeah whatever and by the way the two
Americans hostages released by Hamas
this last Friday 10 more Americans still
uh unaccounted for here so yeah still no
no gold stars we send in whoever we need
to send in we break stuff and uh you
release a hostages or you just keep
getting bombed and you release the
hostages right now I think they're
trying to say We'll release the hostages
if you stop bombing us and I think
that's I think that's a little bit silly
but we'll get to that in just a second
but do me a favor comment below it's not
just my opinion what do you think we
should do how do you think we should
handle the situation when US citizens
are taken
hostage do you think we should just roll
over and let things kind of play out you
guys remember what happened in Iran when
that happened back in the
1970s that that didn't play out too well
I don't remember that about Argo what
you what you what are you in your 30s
part of Argo that was a bit of it I'm
talking about the rest of the hostages
that were held for what was it like 440
something days or 450 days over a year
Americans were held hostage in IR run
yeah I don't think we play around with
it I don't think you negotiate I
certainly don't think you give one point
.25 billion sorry $1.2 billion per
hostage in the Iran deal that we did
most recently that's a really bad
hostage Strat I don't know you tell me
what you think I don't I don't think we
play around with hostage takers I think
every time they take hostages they need
to know that the most sophisticated
military force that the world has ever
known is hunting them down I think
that's you're talking about taking the
profit out of that behavior yeah so I'm
I'm talking about taking the life out of
that
behavior yeah to be more specific put a
finer point right T we're going to knock
the wind out of you permanently yes
permanently you'll never breathe again
yeah good Hamas actually has a hostage
taking strategy Lane like this is
something that you guys kind of pulled
in and I really appreciate it because I
hadn't seen this I I've been looking for
it on on this then right now CNN can
only trip over their smiles about how
happy they are that Jenna Ellis pleads
guilty in the Georgia election case to
kind of strike a plea deal and they're
trying to make this like people are
flipping on Donald Trump that's not
exactly what's happening we'll get to
some of that over the next few days as
more information comes out but the
there's a hostage taking strategy this
is part of their game plan right so they
have an abduction manual they being
Hamas and it was obtained by the IDF and
it basically highlights how important
taking hostages is to the overall
strategy right so here's a few things
that that would be found in uh this
document right so it's binding
instructions which you have no need of
you know very well how to uh bind
someone hand foot yeah from because
because I train in jujitsu yeah I don't
think that's what I was talking about
also live streaming instructions like
what is this a Tik Tok manual here I
don't really understand that like make
sure the lighting is on uh and the the
last part this is kind of chilling if
somebody is a problem kill them kill the
problematic people jeez this is this is
part of what they do this is part of
their existence is taking hostages
that's the like when you get these
people on the internet like this Jackson
Hinkle doofus that keep saying this is
all propaganda by the IDF it's not we're
seeing the live footage that has been
released by Hamas on their telegrams on
their Tik Tok whereever
they're putting it out well also
remember this Israel knew that the
narrative would be taken over and that
people would start to say that in fact
babies weren't beheaded and and burned
and people weren't actually killed right
and so what happens is what they did was
remember Hamas wore body cam I know saw
and the IDF actually showed the horrific
horrific footage was 45 minutes of it to
the Press yeah so that the Press
couldn't also right you know jump on
this sort of moral equivalency bandwagon
which they've done by the way they've
still done it and people on Twitter have
done it and look we've we've I don't
know why this is so hard for people to
understand look at me for one second
just give me your attention anybody out
there right now who is saying that I or
anybody else on this team is pro war
just because we want Israel to be able
to defend themselves is a it
doesn't mean that we want conflict I'm
just saying when conf comes a knocking
we're not backing down that's a very
very different thing being able to
protect yourself and your citizens is a
right that Israel should have when they
take hostages when they keep firing
Rockets when they keep attacking from
this place no no no no no I'm on home
base I'm touching the wall I'm back in
in Gaza does that really matter are you
serious with this like it's Hamas that
we're going after not the people of Gaza
ex we told them are Hamas I know that
that's kind almost one in the same but
it's the leadership in Hamas spe I'm not
they're not going after women and
children specifically in war can bad
things happen 100% should people be held
responsible if they do it intentionally
100% does everybody understand that am I
clear does Israel make mistakes 100% yes
they make mistakes just like everybody
else but they didn't start this fight I
don't care how far back you want to go
they didn't start this fight and why is
it that the Press never mentions the
fact that the best thing to happen to
the Palestinians might be getting rid of
Hamas you know that it absolutely would
be yeah they're they're run by different
militias Hamas is like all these
different factions by the way and the
best thing you could probably do to Gaza
is get rid of those people yeah speaking
of those people a senior leader of Hamas
basm Naim told NBC's Richard angle
hamas's conditions for releasing
releasing the hostages so are you
telling me right now that if the air
strikes stop then the all of the
civilians who I I assume you mean Are
nons Soldiers all of the civilians
Israelis foreigners word they come out
immediately yes this is the what he
announced yesterday and I think it is
still valid and what about have to hold
my phone with two isra soldiers who were
captured you've talked about freeing the
civilians Israelis and foreigners what
are you asking for the Israeli soldiers
to release all our prisoners everything
that guy just say is just all
10,000 of them yeah exactly do do you
buy anything that that guy just said if
you stop the bombing we'll release the
hostages okay here we go how about novel
idea you release the hostages and we
stop the
bombing how does is that does that sound
reasonable we we'll stop shelling you
for a little while you release the
hostages and then we'll take this to
whatever level we need to take it to to
make sure you guys never do this again
but for now let's just get the hostages
or get in a time machine and uh go back
in time and don't take hostages in the
first place and kill a bunch of children
how's that sound what did you think was
going to happen time machine well they
don't have a lot of hot tub out there so
it's it's so interesting to me like
we're going to kill 1400 of your
citizens mostly civilians by the way en
entire families in their pajamas in some
of the most barbaric ways possible but
hey we're going to take and we're going
to film it and we're going to send it to
their families but you know what know
we're sorry don't don't don't come in
yeah well at least former Vice President
Joe Biden said the hostages would need
to be released before a ceasefire could
even be
discussed the usting hostages for
ceasefire deal why did you we should
have a ceas fire we should
have well he he tries to say the right
thing and sometimes he says it wrong and
then says it right but I think what he
meant was that that there's no ceasefire
uh right now but he is trying to delay
the ground Invasion from Israel but I
keep you know what I keep hearing about
this like ceasefire thing to see if you
can resolve a situation
[Music]
[Applause]
peacefully speb
Quin hey ceasefire ceasefire everyone
calm down
he cease fire calm down
guys yeah I don't I don't think that's
going to work no I love that John Wick
just to put the fear of God into him a
little bit more shot the other guy in
the head first he could have killed him
he's like no you need to suffer a wee
bit more I kind of think that's what
should happen to these barbaric animals
that uh took the hostages in the uh
first place I think that the big thing
that's really being undervalued here
that needs to be discussed that needs to
be handled is the qaris in this
situation yeah the US it will be no well
it's not being right now the US needs to
go in there and be incredibly firm with
them they need to they say you turn over
this leadership of Hamas you get the
Hamas leadership ishma Han in your Four
Seasons Hotel in Doha to say You release
these prisoners right now or these
hostages or we're or you're going to be
extradited to the United States but Lane
I think what's really going on is that
the Iranians are being yeah but the
problem here and I think the Israeli are
I think so the Israelis used to make a
distinction between hamas's political
wing and their military wing and now
they're not so anybody who is part of
hamas's political Wing or military Wing
including those in Qatar are on what's
called a hit list and I think then let's
start hitting that list well I you know
they they have their timeline their the
qaris have been propping Hamas up for
Year in 2012 they gave them $400 million
to Hamas directly really and in 20 more
than we're giving to them directly all
of the Gulf States were pressuring qar
that the Saudis had a blockade on them
up until 2020 that was basically choking
them out and saying you have to stop
supporting Terror or your economic
Lifeline is done Trump flip-flopped on
that Biden flip-flopped on that they
wanted this gulf Unity because they were
worried about Iran we need to leverage
our relationship with the Saudis against
the qataris say you do what we say or
we're going to let the Saudis come in
and do whatever they want to you because
the Saudis would take guar like that if
they could only problem is what I told
George we need to tell the Saudis we're
GNA let you do this but we're gonna have
Mickey Mouse selling churos Under the
Clock Tower in Mecca nice think they
would allow that even I don't want
that want
toal the point is we have relationship
to leverage with the Saudis against the
qaris and we have common interest I get
it but yet Joe Biden comes in and calls
them a pariah State listen use his title
former Vice President Joe Biden
I no I understand I understand look we
can leverage our relationships a little
bit better but right now it seems like
what we want to do is just give them
more money which I don't know why we
would do any of that but look last week
if you're if you're a part of mug Club
on our Friday show you actually got a
little bit of a brief discussion on this
uh make sure you join mug Club again uh
we love supporting you guys and talking
to you guys and actually I don't know
doing chat when I say I'm going to do
chat there was a time where I said I was
going to do chat I ended the show and I
was like ah didn't do chat 30 seconds
later we came back on scared people half
to death one of my friends told he was
driving and was hearing kind of like I
guess an outro or just whatever we put
up and all of a sudden it was my voice
and he was like swerving the car a
little bit was like really sorry guys
but'll actually do a lot of that chat
but we got to this a little we're going
to go into it a little bit more here so
if you saw it you're going to get a
little new information but if you didn't
see it this is all brand new to you but
the Biden Administration is seeking to
fund I I would say just Israel but
they're low they're kind of looping in
everything into this Ukraine Israel
domestic affairs buildings they want to
build statues they want to put up
parades I don't know there's probably
all kinds of in there that they would
like to do but they have 105 billion
used to be 100 now it's 105 billion
what's 5 billion between friends right
that's just a rounding err when we're
talking about this much money and they
want it to be funded quickly putting it
before Congress the grand total here is
$105 billion that's the request from the
Biden Administration to Capitol Hill for
new Aid to Israel and to
Ukraine about no money yeah zero money
zero money is a really good place to
start but do me a favor hit the like is
there like a like button the thumbs up
give me a thumbs up give me a like give
me something if you want us to break
down and explain more legislation like
this so you can see what our government
is doing and I think Lane the reason
that you're saying that is because we we
get these packages that are not clear
right on the surface they're they they
title them in ways they're very good at
marketing right they title them in ways
that look good they they throw out
dollar amounts that just you become numb
to seeing billion after a number now
well I would get into this bill and we
can a little bit later it's poor
marketing on their part because this
gives fodder to kind of the right on
Twitter to say 105 billion that's a lot
of cash they're spending your money but
if you break it down it might actually
make a little bit more sense where the
money's going I'm not saying it's a
great Bill no I know so here's why it's
great marketing it's a car alarm now $5
billion dollar you hear it it's kind of
annoying for a second but you don't do
anything like you just keep walking into
the store yeah that's true something
about uh Aid that people forget though
when you hear 105 billion you think of a
blank check that's given to these
countries it's actually not how it works
it's not like in Happy Gilmore where
it's like a big check that they take
home
today so remember when they say $105
billion to Ukraine and to Israel what it
actually means is that they get they're
sending weapons food and other supplies
but those weapons foods and food and
other supplies are made here in the
United States so that money actually
goes to American companies that that
make the products and then send them so
are you talking about the lobbyists it's
kind of a secret way that that both
Republicans and Democrats keep their
their constituents in their their area
happy because what they do is they kind
it's kind of and they do give them some
money as well they do but actually most
of it goes to American companies who
make the goods the weaponry and
everything else and then send it so so
it's kind of a tricky thing it is but
they're trying to sneak in a lot of
stuff into this package because nobody
cares about Ukraine right now have you
guys realized how many stories they've
done on CNN about Ukraine lately like I
think maybe zero is is a really close
estimate it's it's almost zero how about
that that's the probability that you're
going to see a uh a story about Ukraine
right now and zalinski is pissed he's
like in the war in Israel please
whatever happened to Maui I know Maui
doesn't exist anymore well we've moved
on these tragedies that take people's
lives and decimate entire communities
the property yeah it's like whatever
yeah we're totally good all right so
look here here's the the funding bill
it's uh Ukraine is getting 614 billion
44 billion of this is is to replenish
the stockpiles for the United States our
weapons I don't understand how that
counts as AIDS towards them because
we're basically going yeah 44 billion of
this
61.4 going to go into our stock piles
can't you just say we're spending $44
billion on on replenishing our stock I
think it's a good idea to make sure that
we do that we actually covered a lot of
the things that would be needed in a war
if another broad War breaks out in the
Middle East who could possibly see that
coming like what we would need and it
would cost us a lot of money and time to
do it so maybe now's the time to be
doing it I don't know maybe two years
ago was the time to be doing it but
anyway I digress Israel 14.3 billion T
10.6 billion of this is to the Pentagon
for air missile defense support kind of
what you were saying here we get some
money going to some of those defense
contractors and then uh replenishing
stock piles again for 500 there's a
reason lindsy Graham pushes is for the
correct what could that what reason
could that be it could be Boeing it
could be lock be Ron it could be all
those that are in they're very happy
with this Aid pack yes Lindsey Graham's
getting a lot of votes yes it's they're
very happy there are a lot of companies
that go yes Aid comes right to them not
the that's a different Aid no just Aid
plural AIDS it's not you can't just
pluralize it he gave 60 billion AIDS
here's a here's a trivia question for
everybody what is he fouchy whoa I'm
sorry he didn't give AIDS he just let
people die from it my bad you want to
hear here's a tri question what
percentage of the uh us government's
budget go to foreign
aid that's a weird question 10 okay six
1% one a little over 1% hey man you
can't I don't know it's a dumb question
so I was giving you dumb answers it's
not a dumb question but I don't think a
lot of people know that but our budget
is I read that then I like to pretend
that I knew it but it's something I read
I'm quizzing you guys so I can feel
smarter hey Brian how much money is
going to border agents uh no you're
wrong it's 14 billion I know you weren't
going to say 14 billion 14 billion
that's that's almost an entire wall one
would say that maybe building the wall
would be a better place to start than
flooding the border with more agents
yeah walls don't call in sick that's
valid may maybe you would need fewer
agents if you had a wall I don't know
I'm just saying we're going to start
pricing things in terms of Border walls
that could have bought us okay so 105
billion is roughly five border walls
plus some leftover money to make sure
there's enough people to man it with the
turrets and the guns right that kind of
thing all right there we go now we
understand what our money's being used
for all right 9.5 billion or half a
border wall in humanitarian Aid is to be
split between Israel Ukraine and Gaza
now here's the fun part I love it when
people make rules like this because it
means they can do whatever they want
with it the White House said this
funding is
flexible and will go to where it is
needed the most which means wherever
they choose now by the way any time you
want to say that this money is going to
Gaza please understand Hamas is the
government in Gaza so any Aid sent to
Gaza will be going to them now could
there be some NOS or other groups that
they try to bring in or you yeah I
understand that that that's possible but
any money that goes there is suspect in
my book because is going to the people
that are running the war with Israel I'm
sorry I mean the terrorists and the
attacks that they are perpetrating on
those people but there's also some other
stuff that is happening money is going
to the indopacific what would that mean
Lane what is indopacific well here's my
is that Southern Pacific this would be
my biggest problem with the this entire
budget breakdown I mean look at what we
spend on entitlements before you want to
talk to me about military spending I
can't take an argument about military
spending seriously until you want to do
reform but fair as long as we're giving
money
away why we're we're allocating money to
certain place why not allocate most of
this to the Indo Pacific that is still
our biggest problem what we see in
Israel is tragic what's happening to
ukrainians sucks I hate it that is not
our existential threat okay we have one
and we're still footing around
about it and this it's China and this is
an excellent indication of how UNS
seriously we're taking this problem
absolutely well it's people are focused
on something that they shouldn't be
focused on right now shocker it sucks
but people take foreign policy and and
geopolitics so I guess they they don't
treat it with the seriousness that it
deserves and you end up in bad
situations look the the isolationist
ideas that people are propagating right
now have been tried before to very bad
effect I'm the vacuum every every every
single time like it doesn't mean that we
have to be involved in every single War
I I understand that like people are
tired of trying that because it doesn't
work democracy building and nation
building doesn't work but wouldn't you
say wouldn't you say the Ukraine effort
is sort of a a shot across the bow for
China no no I don't think so I I I think
what Lane and I have talked about over
the I guess almost two years now or a
year and a half I can't remember exactly
how long the war has been going on in
Ukraine it's it would have been
initially like we had a moment at the
very beginning of this to go in there
and say hey knock this off and put
everybody back in their neutral Corners
to some degree right in some way some
but now that we've just let it drag on
it has has become very apparent to the
world that we don't take this very
seriously right we should have just said
hey we're not in this we're not funding
this Europe these guys are a part of
your little conglomeration over here you
guys take care of this this is y'all's
problem it's time for you to step up
you've had enough training wheels take
care of your own neighborhood it's not
our job to come in and clean up every
single mess that exists over here there
were two choices and you can argue
whichever one you should have made it's
you do nothing let the Europeans handle
it we focus all of our resources where
they're most important to our strategic
interest or we go in and absolutely end
it as soon as possible that's it kind of
sat in the middle we've depleted our
stockpile we made L people happy yeah
that's what I'm that's exactly what's
been going on in Ukraine they're like ah
we're depleting the Russian military
force for a fraction of our budget I'm
like do you think China cares about the
the Russian military force by the way
the Russian military force doesn't
necessarily look like the biggest I
don't know uh thing to be afraid of in
the world right now they're having a
hard time taking over Ukraine anyway let
me just move on for a second here
because there's big problem that this
White House is trying to leverage right
now and look Matt Gates I don't know if
you just like to watch the world burn or
if you had a plan in the plan just fell
apart look I can understand that that
happens but right now we don't have a
speaker which means no laws are being
passed the Biden Administration it no
this is not good here's why right now we
should be talking about former Vice
President Joe Biden's economy sucking
and his handling of a war and what the
news media is doing and they'll find
something every single time to spin but
this is a gift no speaker can't pass any
laws can't put anything into effect we
can't Aid Israel oh sorry support Israel
we gota can't yet because nothing can
get going in the house and the Biden
Administration is lumping everything
together to gain broad bipartisan
support and everything is deadlocked my
question to you how do you think the
deadlock in Congress will affect these
wars I understand maybe it's a good
thing to hold up some funding right and
we don't want to spend money in places
that we shouldn't be spending money
maybe that's Ukraine but my problem with
that is the Optics of it are incredibly
bad and I do think we should be sending
some money to some places I just don't
think we should be sending money to all
of the places that they're listing right
so we need to do something and we can't
right now and bad bad time for the
republicans in Congress yeah Gerald Matt
Gates didn't have a plan I think I think
he's running for governor of Florida and
he's all about Matt Gates is he I I mean
I don't know I don't think I I think
he's more into destruction I I just I
don't think there was a plan there some
people just want to watch the world burn
Brian get rid of McCarthy and then we'll
just make a bunch of noise and I want
all the attention I don't know what
happens after that but look I understand
it frustrates a lot of people but there
are some practical issues that it's
bringing up but one of the other things
that we need to make sure is focused on
is the Border we've talked about border
walls again five border walls in the new
funding package I'm just going to start
pricing everything on Border walls it's
like using crypto it's like 0.8 of
Bitcoin right um according to a memo by
the US Customs and Border Patrol the cpb
from here on out border officials
arrested 18 people this is just the
arrests 18 people on the FBI's Terror
watch list in September alone damn
suspected terrorists could use the
southern border to gain entry into the
United States that conc has escalated in
recent days as the Israel Hamas War
rages on could have never seen this
coming I was talking with Lane before
the show about this and I said one of my
favorite authors jel C Rosenberg has a
new book out I think it's he's gonna
kill me it's Libya Invasion or or the
the Libya I can't remember the name of
it somebody look it up Joel C Rosenberg
Libya book anyway the whole the whole
like plot of this book is a terrorist
coming into the United States through
the southern border and it's not like
I'm saying he's calling it I'm just
saying that that's part of it and he's
like wait a minute the entire new series
of Jack Ryan on Amazon was about that
and I'm like yeah and he's like and by
the way there was also like a Tom Clancy
book that was about that and it's not
that Joel's book is in any way like
copying that the the idea of the
Southern border being used by terrorists
is so obvious to everyone except
apparently the government that they're
using it as the plot of their stories
why do we keep giving them ideas I don't
I don't know but it's a really really
bad thing and everybody is on board with
this like yeah that's absolutely that's
not going to lose the audience they're
going to be able to follow that they can
see these numbers except for the White
House and by the way the terrorist watch
list that I was talking about the cpb
terror watch list encounters at the
border in the past 12
months 169 terrorists have been arrested
that's more than the last six years
combined under Donald Trump the grand
total 11 wow wow 11 those are almost
different numbers Trump was in the white
house for how many years as president of
the United States yeah yeah total so far
under Joe
Biden
282 wow
this is scaring the hell out of me
because normally what you do it's like a
multiple right you say like okay we
catch one in five terrorists maybe I'm
really hoping the number is like higher
than that and it's four out of five but
let's just use it to so we catch one in
five Terrace so multiply the number by
five right right and that's how many are
trying to again in you know one of those
five doesn't get in but four do that's
really bad right now if you do that
under Joe Biden they've got basically
the population of a state like they they
there's so many people coming in the
border right now that you've got
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people on terror watch lists that have
made it through successfully in the
United States I understand it maybe not
that high of a number but really how
many does it take yeah right but here
here's here's the good here's the good
news right luckily every once in a while
they get sloppy and we actually do catch
one h huh it's never much of a Mr Bean
fan anyway I'm glad he's going to do
life yeah so let's just say real quick
that these are not terrorists and we
have other unfettered illegal
immigration coming in from these Middle
Eastern countries as you've seen in
places like Dallas or New York and you
see hundreds of thousands of pro
Palestinian Marchers and ostensibly
they're Marching for What free Palestine
right that's a terrorist slogan I'm
sorry it is now yeah guess what this
poll a majority of Muslim Americans say
hamas's attacks on Israel were Justified
on October 7th yes I I think we should
be careful about
polls well but it the fact that the
majority of these people ped said that
is a pretty big deal but I think there
are a lot of Israelis see I I don't
think my feeling is that we get if we
start getting into Muslim and we start
getting into the Israeli Palestinian um
conflict I believe that that's a whole
different subject right so so you could
say all those things and there's there's
we can go on for days hours years my
feeling is that October 7th should stand
as its own atrocity where there's look
you cannot justify that kind of behavior
well that's what he's saying the poll
said they were justifying that specific
behavior I understand I and I understand
what you're saying L I'm just saying
that I think it's really important
though to kind of like focus on making
sure we don't make moral equivalencies
and what's what's going on in the
mainstream media is they're saying
you're bombing Gaza and killing children
that is true and that's the same as
coming over on on a holiday you know war
and killing a bunch of children
everybody else and taking hosit that is
not true it is not and it's really
important keep yeah no no I'm just
saying Lane I think it's really
important that we keep that distinction
and then keep the other discussion
almost separate right it's almost like
the Israeli Palestinian thing yes we can
have that conversation um right but that
so let me just be clear you just quoted
a poll that was really focused on
October 7 so he is got it on this the
polling company private polling company
and yes you have to take polls let's say
there's a let's say there's a 30% margin
of error that's still one out of five
yeah that would who think October 7th
was fine and the reason I don't have a
hard time believing this unfortunately
is because I was at one of these places
and not one person would condemn what
happened yeah to my face not one is that
can I just as a to play Devil's Advocate
only because I just want to I think it's
important that we is it possible that
right now because emotions are so high
people are yeah I don't no yeah man see
see I I agree with you guys I agree with
you guys you're talking I know what
you're trying to do and I it's it's a
valiant effort but no they are terrorist
lived in the Middle East for eight years
of my life and I I have to say again I
think to your point guys it's like you
you you have to condemn that you cannot
you cannot not condemn that you cannot
say it's Justified oh I cut I cut her
head off but my mom was mean to me like
yeah no there is no justification for
this and look I it's it's one of those
it's one of those things that you can
get lost in the weeds a little bit here
that's why I said a minute ago I don't
care how far back you want to go right
you guys want to go all the way back to
before Israel was fine fantastic let's
do that you want to go through all the
atrocities that have happened since then
but fine fantastic let's do that there's
one country right now where Muslims
Christi Christians and Jews live
relatively peacefully in the Middle East
and that's Israel nobody else has gotten
it right nobody else has gotten it right
in that region period tomorrow if Hamas
wanted peace they could negotiate a
peace with Israel if they truly meant it
Israel would be ready to do that but
Hamas will never do that because in
their Charter it is the extinction of
the Jews period when you put that as
your founding document you're kind of
staking your claim from from The River
To The Sea means we're going to kill all
of you just be clear on what we're
talking about here Israel doesn't have a
constitution or a founding document that
says kill all Muslims and push them into
the sea that doesn't exist that's what I
mean when I say it's a terrorist slogan
I don't mean the children in the halls
of San Francisco high schools yelling
they don't know they don't know and
people saying free Palestine what
they're listening to AOC and rashita T
and ilon Omar those moronic crazy people
who are trying to make this about aness
rest class that's not what's happening
right now tell you what Rashida T Ilan
Omar part of anybody who wants to be a
part of the squad or Squad adjacent you
tell me how an organization can call for
the extermination of a people and have
peace with those people I don't think
it's possible because it's not possible
the last thing I want to say before
anything gets misconstrued here on this
show as being islamophobic that's not
the case and it's America and anyone
should have the right to practice the
religion they want to and there should
never any violence directed at any
ethnicity or religious group at all
period no just because just because
people are Muslim in countries doing
things you don't like it would be very
stupid to just see a Muslim here and go
bad person same thing with Maga right
where we're talking about hey we got a
Maga person over here and the guy get
shot that's stupid too like you don't
you can disagree with Joe Biden You can
disagree with Donald Trump and not hate
everybody that's associated with them
though it's harder on the Joe Biden side
because a lot of those people are really
really terrible I just wouldn't say hate
there does have to be a reconciliation
with what we do with there does with
this sort of vitriol that's Rising
between groups well let me let me ask a
question really quickly so and and this
is that you know you're you're a man who
can handle himself in a fight right
you're very very well trained I'll keep
you busy by mass shoulders look at
shoulders okay so look I I don't know if
you guys have actually done this and
this is something that I I I don't want
you look I was going to say hit like
don't don't do that I want you to
comment on this and I really look I when
I say that this is not like hey let's
drive interaction and see what happens I
want to know what you think I want to
know what you are thinking right now
because this is like this giant sample
size that we have of people that are
going to watch this show over a million
people I want to know what you guys
think about what I'm about to say when I
go out to my car in the morning I'm more
cautious now that doesn't mean that I'm
like H I'm scared or anything like that
but I'm like okay things are a little
crazy I don't necessarily know that it's
coming to where I live or to where
anybody here lives but I'm just a little
bit more cautious I'm a little bit more
cautious when I go to big crowds big
gatherings just a little bit just to
make sure that I have some situational
awareness not I'm not so distracted that
I can't live my life I'm not living in
fear or anything like that but are you
taking extra precautions right now like
are you a little bit more aware of your
surroundings are you a little bit more
on edge because of some of this stuff
not because of your neighbor who's
happens to be Muslim I I have plenty of
people that I know in my neighborhood
that are Muslims no problems whatsoever
I'm not worried about them because of
their faith I'm not saying well ah jeez
these guys are Muslims so therefore
they're probably terrorists you know but
it does make me a little bit more
concerned in other situations and I
think there's a lot of people like that
right now makes me more concerned when I
go to church yeah right because churches
can be a Target and if people can
justify to your Point Lane October 7th
they can justify anything anything to
reach that end so and I think you know
I'm sorry but the people that commit a
lot of these this violence have earned
that
reputation right you got tow you know
it's like I remember in 2002 when when
when they the suicide bombing started
going off and Israelis were just getting
blown to bits now and I think Dian fste
or somebody said what is Ariel Chiron
supposed to do write a letter to the
editor like what do you what would you
do and if
violence again like I don't believe in
building settlements on on Palestinian
land you can have that point of view you
can say I think that the farri religious
fundamentalists in Israel might be
building land on what they blah blah you
can get into this that's fine you want
to get into this conversation but at the
end of the day if you're going to blow
yourself up and you're going to kill a
bunch of civilians and if you think
that's going to get you anywhere Israel
has a duty to its citizens and to the
moral code to say no way what if it was
happening here we would go what I'm
saying bistic dude think about it think
about it right now what if this happened
in your neighborhood what if they killed
your what if they killed your kids or
they took your grandmother uh hostage
what would you well Grandma no I'm just
kidding that's true by the way yeah I
love grandma she needs your medication
yeah both of my grammar are dead so you
can't take them great they do vote
though great now I'm depressed so by the
way I just I just want you to know like
the Biden Administration they know about
all of this right and and the DHS is
kind of referring back to the numbers of
the terrorists coming over and the
apprehensions and the craziness that's
going on at the border they know about
all of this and the dhs's 2024 Homeland
threat assessment it probably States
white supremacy is the problem now they
actually do know that this is a problem
as well they just T typically focus on
white supremacists and this is a quote
from individuals with terrorism
connections are interested in using
established travel routes and permissive
environments to facilitate access to the
United States here let me rewrite that
for you can we pull that back up let me
rewrite that I'm just going to take a
pen to this individuals who are
terrorists not with terrorism
connections I think they can rewrite
that a little bit better are interested
in using
known travel routes where nobody gives
an f and they can just walk right in I'm
talking about the southern border where
we don't have a wall narrated by Gerald
Morgan Jr I think that's better to the
point does everybody understand like
that's what they're talking about and in
fact it leaked internal cpb CBP memo you
down with OP dated October 20th 2023
warns this San Diego field office
intelligence unit assesses that
individuals inspired by or reacting to
the current Israel Hamas conflict may
attempt to travel to or from the area of
hostilities in the Middle East across
the Southwest
border
so wall 20 billion can we go back to
that five walls that we're about to send
5.25 walls is are being sent over in Aid
right now I just think we could take one
of those walls out of it and send 4.25
walls and keep one for ourselves is it
weird that it's easier for terrorists to
get across our Southwest border than it
is for Palestinians to get across their
Southwest border into Egypt into a
friendly country that says that they are
in the world's largest outdoor open air
prison I mean if they are I mean you got
some gates to the prison we're not
locking it do you guys think we're going
to see do you guys think we're going to
see more Palestinians eventually start
saying thank God Hamas is no longer here
like I feel like that's around the
corner I think it's possible it just
depends like they're very good at
propaganda the whole Hospital thing that
we completely debunked and still to this
day people are running with it like it
actually happened what was it the Wall
Street Journal had photos up of like a
another bombed out building because they
couldn't find photos of the hospital to
make it look like that was the hospital
that had been bombed which it hadn't if
you want the worst picture I think I've
seen yet from the protest from the war
you can okay that up Matt reproductive
Justice Means free P oh jez oh my God
talk about hijacking talk about
hijacking a situation if you cannot
abort a baby no
piece wow what a-holes just a group of
a-holes I don't understand you it's like
are you trying to piggyback every set of
victimized status on the planet onto the
Israel climate yeah yeah where's the
climate I love there's a Greta thunberg
one on on X where she's somebody dubbed
over and made it look pretty close to
what she was saying like please use
biodegradable bombs if you can because
really the bombs are the problem I'm
like what a lot of people Shar that like
it was real though I know they're idiots
they're really really stupid listen I
hope it's not you but the law of big
numbers says maybe it is watching this
show there might be one but most of you
are very smart and I I we pride
ourselves in knowing that our audience
is not full of idiots we really do we
know that you are not stupid and that's
why we're giving you some of this
information you just have other stuff in
your life to do but if there is one
idiot out
there that's not real she's not saying
that there's so so many things like that
that are fake on X that people run with
that like and I could spend most of my
day just going that's not real that's
not real and just retweeting something
with a quote or reposting yeah and I I
have no time like if you're dumb enough
to just fall for this hookline and
seeing I there's nothing I can do for
you but they how dare you I dare and
look let me just move on really quickly
because we're running a little bit late
here specifically the memo does list
individuals associated with Hamas
Hezbollah the Palestinian Islamic Jihad
you remember those guys the popular
front for liberation of Palestine and
didn't didn't the Islamic Jihad guys
they're the ones that fired that rocket
that didn't make it to its intended
target instead ended up in the parking
lot of a hospital burning cars knocking
out a handful of Windows and not killing
500 people not wounding 600 on top of
that I don't think we've seen
retractions though yeah Rockets they
have cheap Rockets well they they make
them out of the water pipes that the
Israelis and the rest of the world gave
them so that they could have their own
water and instead they'd rather be a
victim class and shoot rockets at Israel
but hey peace let's go for a ceasefire
you first not surprising considering
illegal Crossings at the southern border
have boomed under Biden September alone
saw
269,900 per month on Donald Trump's
watch it was around 40,000 per month and
look that's lower right hey at least Co
cheaper right guys yeah exactly right so
uh unfortunately the authorities also
accidentally released a terrorist much
must watch list I should say right and
uh it it is quite quite Reckless and it
includes U you know films like United 93
Air Force One Kate and Leopold and uh
yeah that that last one there is just
brutal that's that's rough that is
pretty brutal
yeah Shakespeare in Love it's not
actually well it could be no that's your
opinion listen I want you to remember
those are the ones that are actually
caught I made that case earlier if you
missed it if you came in late to class
look at somebody else's notes because I
talked to you about that if you're only
catching that many how many are getting
past you I don't think you really know
but usually it's a bit of a multiple and
uh it's not good and look don't expect
former Vice President Joseph Biden
Joseph robinet Biden to do anything
about the Border after all he he thinks
that disenfranchising US citizens with a
Non-Stop unrelenting stream of
immigration uh is one heck of a plan an
unrelenting stream of
immigration
nonstop
non-stop folks like me cultural en
Caucasian of European descent for the
first time in 2017 will be an absolute
minority in the United States of America
absolute minority fewer than 50% of the
people in America from then and on will
be white European in stock that's not a
bad thing but don't forget it's also
wrong don't forget he doesn't want the
immigrants to ever really be in a place
of power we already have a may we
don't need any more big
shots wow stuck the r Joe I wouldn't
keep doing that well that's that's right
you said it and it's on tape and you
can't really undo that but you're 100%
right he's wrong and that's not
fantastic that that you shouldn't having
a white minority shouldn't be a thing
that you're I don't think it it
accomplishes anything in and of itself
why is that a goal doesn't matter like
it's not solving oh you you think that
white people are the problem and in that
case then yeah having a minority of
white people and having that makes a lot
of sense to you you think that white
people are the extremist and the
terrorist okay I I totally understand
that yeah because most terrorist attacks
in the world uh uh at least in the last
you know 50 years have been committed by
white guys but you know that's just me I
maybe I missed it I don't know I'm not
saying that white guys are great I'm
saying that sometimes maybe not calling
them domestic terrorists just because
they think that freedom is a good thing
would be a place to start Joe don't go
to to PTA meetings and arrest parents
protesting that's fair because if you do
take an interest in your child's
education and the indoctrination that
the government is subjecting them to
that you're probably a radical and you
need to be dealt with and uh we need to
get on that to be fair though to be fair
to be fair we did just recently get all
the Asians as whites also because they
got really good at math and making money
so they've kind of been Accord according
to a bunch of school districts on the
west coast as are now white so you know
population is increasing yeah there's a
district in Oregon that said well you're
going to be counted as white now
basically because they were scoring too
high well let me be the first to say
welcome yeah yes you're now not
protected in any way it's going to suck
how's stop Asian part of the problem
they're part of the problem that Tim
where' that movement go yeah stop Asian
hate went away but look do you think the
next terror attack do do you
guys a lot of you who watch this show
because of our demographics were either
really young maybe not born or maybe
around 10 years old when a lot of this
was going on but the reason that I
started doing this with Stephen Back In
20156 Radio Days was because of
terrorism I I helped teach a class
called a Christian's response to Islam
by the way it's not blowing them up it's
loving them and understanding where
people are coming from in Islam not just
it's not talking about terrorists
necessarily because that's going to be
kind of a fruit a fruitless situation to
try to deal with but it's not talking
about like he said we're not denigrating
an entire people just because they're
Muslim like I I taught this class it was
because of the terrorist attacks like I
I studied their eschatology I studied
their end times theology to understand
what was driving them I studied how
salvation can be found and it's only
guaranteed through Jihad right and so
you start to understand what motivates
people and so we started seeing
terrorist attack after September 11th
tons of terrorist attack attacks around
the world and I came on to talk about
that and then it went away for a little
while and then they started focusing on
white people right so the demand for
terrorism outstripped Supply so they're
like all right we're going to focus on
domestic terrorists and start kind of
getting in and denza gets into that in
his movie the police state which is out
he was out yesterday in theaters and
it's also out tomorrow good doc I
watched it absolutely fantas do actually
yeah we we aired the interview that I
did with him yesterday but the my my
problem and my question to you is do you
think that that next terrorist attack
that we haven't had to worry about on us
soil for a long time is coming back to
us soil do you think that somebody who
crossed over the southern border under
former Vice President Joe Biden's open
border policy is going to commit an act
of Terror that now we have to worry
about on American soil or do you think
white guys that like to drink beer every
once in a while really the problem that
we need to clean up all right look
there's I'm going to do a a really quick
kind of setup into this and then we're
going to go into mug club and I'm going
to give you more information but I I've
I've been looking back based on some of
the cases that we've seen with Trevor
Bower and the punter what's his name mat
Arisa I always want to say aara and it's
not right I know he's but he's the punt
God was his nickname and that was you
don't become a punt God unless you're
very good at punting because most people
don't care about punters they come out
they do their job and they collect you
know a million-dollar paycheck and
that's great and all but nobody really
cares about them nobody wears their
jerseys around except for maybe their
family but this guy was accused of
sexual assault and found to be innocent
he wasn't there he wasn't yeah there was
no there there when it happened
literally wasn't at the party yeah
wasn't at the party yes she said me and
he raped me and and everybody got on
this kid he wasn't at the party and the
the police figured that out right quick
y the da and the mistake he made in my
opinion your lawyers tell you to keep
your mouth shut no don't keep your mouth
shut never again that's a bad strategy
shout from the top of the mountain yep
exactly we talked about Trevor Bower and
we talked about the legal Shenanigans
from certain a-holes out in California
that knew about this being complet
completely false still put it out there
that he did this and cost this guy
potentially his career in baseball he's
trying to come back into the United
States I think right now maybe meeting
with some teams we'll see I hope that
goes don't want to deal with it the
problem is you're ruining people's lives
on lies MH now stopping sexual assault
is good this is almost the inverse of
the Hitler bad thing right stopping
sexual assault good right that's
fantastic how about this rape bad sexual
assault bad absolutely should we stop
more of it absolutely me too went too
far we we became the Salem Witch Trials
guys do you understand that look back on
some of these cases look back on the
people's lives that are ruined and still
they are being ruined even though
they're cleared even though evidence
comes out to completely exonerate them
they are still having their lives ruin
really quickly last week a federal judge
found ex Baylor football coach art BS to
be not negligent surrounding allegations
from a 2014 14 sexual assault case the
Baylor Title 9 lawsuit trial continued
today at the federal courthouse in Waco
today the judge dismissed former Baylor
football coach art BRS and former
athletic director Ian mcau from the
lawsuit ruling no reasonable jury could
find them negligent for the 2014
domestic violence assaults of a former
Baylor student by a former football
player do you think ESPN cares they're
going to cover it for 5 seconds you know
what they covered at length the
WNBA I hate that by the way ESPN stop we
still don't care I don't care if the
aces have won four championships or
whatever the heck the number is nobody
cares do you know what they covered they
covered when
Oklahoma played I can't remember Kansas
State I I remember the game that they
played but art bals because his
son-in-law is a coach there came down on
the field with the rest of the family
with the rest of the family not
specifically him after the game and
stood with some of the players and was
singing the fight song being there with
his family and people got upset about
that Venable had to make a statement
about that after the game saying we've
talked about this and that was that was
it shouldn't have
happened right I I don't understand
what's going on here when you cover that
like that is bad you remember this guy
he's the guy the sexual assault stuff
that he allowed to go on and he knew
everything that's exactly the kind of
thing that they are saying and this has
followed this man his entire life a
brilliant
guy who did according to these reports
and according to other reports that
we're going to dive into a little bit
more we'll give you a bit of a teaser
today and I'm going to go into mug club
and talk about it a little more but you
need to understand we have been ruining
people's lives on lies and speculation
for years and it has to stop it does not
serve your goals if you're trying to
stop r and sexual assault it only makes
people not believe any of the
accusations anymore even if they're true
you have to stop this we cannot have
another Brett Kavanagh situation ever
again we cannot have another art bals
Mel Tucker going on right now Trevor
Bower just find out about the the
finally releasing the information to us
and letting us know that it wasn't true
we have to stop this we're going to do a
deeper dive we might even do a super
video on it because there's that many
cases going on where people's lives are
continuing to be ruined
and it has to stop right now I'm sorry I
know this is a third rail I don't care
people's lives are being ruined you have
to talk about it it's important we're
going to talk a little bit more in mug
Club but thank you guys for joining us
we really do appreciate it make sure if
you are not a member of mug club that
you sign up for mug club today Brian
where are you going to be Friday and
Saturday in Chicago but not Chicago
chicag improv shamber improv Chicago
improv Chicago impr October 27th October
28th 27th and 28 make sure you go out
and support him and do do him a favor
and and please favorite song when you
see him that I'm Too Sexy there you go
and make sure you talk about his
shoulders YouTube they go on for days
you know
what I'd love to be able to talk about
this on your platform but you guys are
pansy so piss
[Applause]
off
yeah